also ich hoffe wir kriegen ein auto was
wirklich extrem günstig ist meine wir
dürfen das heutige videos 50 euro ja das
hört sich extrem wenig an für ein auto
ich habe da von bmw gesehen sondern
unser mobiler sie doch woraus ist sehr
wichtig
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut heute mit
einem ganz speziellen thema und zwar
geht es heute um autos ich weiß es
interessiert nicht jeden aber es geht
jetzt nicht speziell um irgendwie so ein
bestimmtes modell oder so es geht
einfach darum wie günstig kann ein auto
sein wenn man es halt gebraucht kauft
ich habe mit dem format nicht jetzt mal
vor drei vier wochen angefangen da habe
ich den günstigsten flug gebucht falls
das noch nicht gesehen habt schickt es
auf jeden fall ab also da wird es auf
jeden fall in zukunft mehr träger zu
geben also was heißt das schon am namen
aber es geht halt immer um das
günstigste produkt die günstigste
dienstleistung die man suchen kann
oder kaufen kann und wie das dann halt
ist und heute habe ich mich einfach mal
für autos entschieden einfach weil ich
mich sehr für autos interessiere und ich
einen kontakt bekommen habe wo ich
glaube ich an einer vernünftigen adresse
bin für das günstigste auto der welt
nenne ich jetzt mal also ich hoffe wir
kriegen ein auto was wirklich extrem
günstig ist man begegnet das heutige
videos 50 euro ja das hört sich extrem
wenig an für ein auto und wir schauen
wir ob wir damit ein auto kriegen was
auch wirklich fährt um euch das mal ein
bisschen zu zeigen ich bin ja auf
mobile.de hier gibt es halt autos und
ich habe gerade mal eingegeben preis bis
100 euro
45 angebote das schauen wir mal rein und
und hier kann man direkt sehen
20 euro das günstigste was ja gut das
hier ist ein euro aber das ist denke ich
mal ist wahrscheinlich verhandlungs
basis hier haben wir dann ford fiesta
für 20 euro kann er noch fahren
es hat sich euro alter das ist schon
verrückt aber die meisten autos hier
kosten also 990 euro haben viele
eingestellt ich bin mir unsicher ob
dieser preis 20 euro wirklich
realistisch sein kann kann man dann auch
für 20 euro kaufen lassen was einen
wirklich von a nach b bringen also
wasser fährt halte ich für sehr
unrealistisch wir probieren das mal mit
50 euro und schauen ob wir dafür ein
auto kriegen also ich bin gespannt
es geht jetzt gleich los ich habe
deutschland mal angerufen wir haben
einen termin um 11 uhr wie gesagt
schreibt mir super gerne ideen für
weitere videos das günstigste der
günstigste die günstigste was auch immer
in die kommentare
bin ich gespannt darauf lege ich mir
alles durch versprochen und jetzt geht's
los
so leute also ich habe mich jetzt
angezogen ich hoffe der sound ist gut
ich nehme das ganze mal wieder
miteinander
kann man auf und wir fahren da jetzt hin
so leute
auf geht's so leute ich bin angekommen
glaube ich also irgendwie sie das hier
so ein bisschen unbeliebt wir stehen
zwar überall autos ja also ist auf jeden
fall so ein auto hoch auf dem weg hin es
war eigentlich alles voll mit autos und
diese autos die da oben drauf stehen ich
muss mal kurz auf die andere kann man
zwischen hier kann man nämlich so gut
dran so ein paar leute schaue ich mal
die autos an
so eins wäre nicht schlecht wenn 52 an
die kameras und bestimmt auch ganz
entspannt mitnimmt ich finde diese
vorstellung wirklich so krass so ein
dickes auto da ist ja so viel material
mit drin
für 20 euro da ist jemand und dann kann
es sogar auch noch fahren es fährt und
es ist hat also das ist für mich
wirklich krass na ja ich will gar nicht
lange aber jetzt mal was es heute wird
auch hier der werde auch aufgeführt 20
euro oder aber dann darf man gar nicht
anfassen leute ab hier muss ich leider
nach synchronisieren das mikrofon hat so
gewackelt und ich wollte dass ich an tun
deswegen wir sind über das gelände
gegangen haben uns ein paulus angeguckt
da gibt es auch ganz normale autos sind
so also war ganz interessant hab auch
ein paar coole autos gesehen und jetzt
geht es wohl wieder so leute also hier
stehen wirklich eine menge autos die
komplett schrott sind und die auch so
also die kauft niemand mehr zum beispiel
dieses ding hier das sieht zwar für mich
auch überhaupt nicht mal so aus aber
kann man hier kann man es noch sehen das
war mal ein porsche die reifen dabei
auch komplett zerstört ich habe gehört
viele autos die hier stehen wurden bei
cobra 11 benutzer das ding sieht jacke
drin ist sondern eine rote jacke oder so
das auto für das ich mich allerdings
interessieren
das steht da hinten und das ist denn bmw
der ist extrem alt und er sieht auch
extrem schrott aus also ich bin mir noch
nicht sicher wie viel er kosten wird
aber ich tippe mal so also mehr als 150
euro wirklich dafür niemals aufgeben
weil das denken sich wirklich schrott
aus ich kann sich gern mal zeigen wie
geht es aber erstmal rein ich will noch
ein bisschen und dann schauen wir mal
wer uns den gleich verkaufen kann und ob
ich denn überhaupt kaufen kann aber ich
denke schon also ich hab das war also
ein bisschen abgeklärt das hier
natürlich auch nicht schlecht
das ist einfach so ein dhl auto ist dass
offen
schade da sollte schon mal drin sitzen
also ich habe es gerade schon mal raus
bekommen das hier ist das auto es sieht
wirklich sehr heruntergekommen aus es
kommt aus dem jahr 1989 also 1989 er
baujahr das krasse ist ist es sogar bmw
aber wenn ich mir das so anschaue also
mehr als 50 euro gebe ich da nicht aus
vielleicht 70 ich weiß ich hab ich den
man für so was kriege ich würde sagen
bevor wir aber mal schauen was wir da
preis ich machen können gibt es ein
kurzes kap horn und
[Musik]
jetzt sogar auf 197 1500 31 kilometer
also hat er schon leute also sieht das
auto von hinaus ich finde gar nicht mal
so schlecht um ehrlich zu sein
ja wenn ich mir schlimmer vorgestellt
kann man hier kann man jetzt sehen 107
90.000 kilometer runter leute wie viel
ps er hat weiß ich leider nicht ich
würde mal so schätzen maximal 100
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr keine
ahnung und hinten ist sogar noch eine
rückbank ich denke mir gerade wenn ich
dir jetzt wirklich mitnehmen was macht
ihnen denn damit ich weiß nicht das
könnt ihr mehr denn meine kommentare
schreiben wenn ich dieses auto jetzt
kaufe was mache ich dann damit oder was
soll ich damit machen schreibt wendy
kommentare ich würde sagen wir gehen
jetzt einfach mal rein
also ich hab das ja natürlich abgeklärt
dass wir kurz was auch nehmen dürfen
und dann schauen wir mal wie teuer denn
das günstigste auto oder eher wie
günstig das günstigste auto ist wir sind
hier bei auto das geht in köln können ja
gerne vorbeischauen
ja auf jeden fall ein paar coole autos
hier stehen und mal gucken welches ich
jetzt mitnehmen ich bin gespannt also
dass ich hab das ja schon gezeigt steht
sogar ein ferrari da kostet allerdings
bisschen mehr als mein budget stehen auf
jeden fall ein paar nette autos so denn
da finde ich auch gut
denn was für mein opa leute wieder zur
stelle ins büro und dann gucken wir mal
weil darum geht es ja auch eigentlich
mikrofon problem nummer zwei
hier waren wir im büro und jetzt geht's
los
ich interessiere mich von auto also es
soll sehr günstig seien
ich habe davon so ein bmw gesehen der
sieht doch so aus und ermöglicht den zu
kaufen
wir könnten
juni wir brauchen den platz musste
also ich habe mir also ein budgetgesetz
ist jetzt einfach unserem video thema
das wäre 50 euro wer das wäre es zu
wenig da mit dem wiederaufbau
also ich 50 euro am anfang habe ich
irgendwas von 20 euro gesagt aber ich
glaube dass zu wenig angeht weil wir
nicht haben ein kleines problem heute
war es noch ganz wichtig ist damit es
auch zu einer verwirrung kommt unter den
autoexperten der unterricht das ding ist
natürlich braucht er noch
nummernschilder also ich musste erst
anmelden der hat doch ein halbes jahr
tüv das würde ich machen ich weiß nicht
ob ich das doch mit in dieses video
nehme ich habe aber gerade gefragt ich
darf natürlich hier auf dem hof ein
erfahren umzusehen oder ihr damit ihr
seht okay das auto kann wirklich fahren
und das ist möglich ist für so wenig
geld und ein auto zu kaufen
ich glaube das ist das älteste auto
nehme ich jesus
du bist dir sicher das ist damals ja
deshalb so bunt sind doch die ganze zeit
unfälle passieren
die leute haben
also
auch die straße traue ich mich damit
nicht dass wir hart backbord
so leute wieder zurück ich habe ja
diesen parkplatz und in köln sind
parkplätze wirklich extrem teuer hier
zum beispiel die parkplätze gehören
meinen nachbarn
das heißt ich habe eigentlich so gar
keine ahnung wo ich den abstellen soll
erstmal einmal wahren freund von mir der
hat so ein grundstück da könnte ich den
park wie gesagt leute also schreibt mir
sehr gerne die kommentare was ich mit
dem auto machen soll
es ging halt nur jetzt mal darum zu
schauen für wie viel geld man wirklich
so ein auto bekommen kann also praktisch
heute so als kleines experiment und das
ist halt jetzt herausgekommen
ich habe sogar die möglichkeit dass auch
mal andersrum zu machen und zwar das
teuerste auto was ich natürlich dann
logischerweise nicht kaufen kann aber
ich kann es zumindest mal probe fahren
wenn ihr darauf dort hat dann gebt mir
auf jeden fall langsam nach oben bei
5.000 würde ich sagen macht mal das mal
dann mit dem teuersten auto das wir auf
jeden fall schon krass ja also das war
es eigentlich auch schon mit dem video
ich wollte am ende aber noch mal kurz
sagen vielen dank an das kinn automobile
dass ich oder das hier überhaupt gesagt
habe das ist ok dass wir das film also
weil das macht ja auch nicht jeder das
was ich da ist gekauft habe war wirklich
eine schrottkiste und ich glaube
wirklich dass billigste vom billigsten
also die haben auch andere coole autos
wollte ich mir mal gesagt haben also
schöne grüße und das war's von mir wie
gesagt schreibt weitere ideen für das
die den duden günstigsten sonstwas in
die kommentare von wir sehen uns
mittwoch wieder ich habe es gleich ein
friseurtermin und alter das video
mittwoch wir glaube ich heftig